we help basically deal makers push the
deal forward by being more attuned more
aware of the subtleties
um that are mostly nonverbal for example
uh how your voice sounds
how your body interesting you know is
seen your hand gestures your micro
expressions even stuff in email that are
not very trivial for example uh your
response time okay
the the relative length of your email
versus the other person
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community
fund in silicon valley in partnership
with lomitek and sponsored by homeward
ventures hippo insurance opposed hillel
stanford leap and birthright excel an
immediate partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet ori
manor zuckerman co-founder and ceo of
substrata
meet ori a serial entrepreneur born and
raised in israel he served in a special
naval intelligence unit in the idf and
founded several companies including
volusia ventures discover cloud data vis
acquired by evocative and unomi acquired
by wework today he is leading substrata
a non-verbal communication ai startup
that helps deal makers get a unique
advantage in complex deals through
innovative social signal processing
technology
holy manor zuckerman thank you so much
for joining me on 20 minute leaders how
are you i'm good thank you
thank you very very much for joining me
today
i'm excited to talk to you about your
your own life journey you have a
fascinating journey as a serial
entrepreneur and having gone through
quite a variety of different fields and
occupations so i'm excited to to pick
your brain on on those pieces and then
leading towards the current company that
you're running substrata and talking a
little bit about you know deal making
about negotiations and what does it mean
to actually close a sale and not just
from an intuitive perspective but but a
little bit more hands-on with how can we
actually become better at it through
deep technology and so already tell me a
little bit about yourself and and
different milestones in your journey
that led you towards of strata
okay so wow it's a big question um
just you know in bullet points on 40 i'm
married with a baby i uh i live in tel
aviv i served in uh a naval intelligence
unit in the idf uh i founded a couple
companies including trx identification
company discover cloud b2b south
marketplace database was acquired by
vocative you know me that was acquired
by wework and today obviously as you
said i'm leading some strata i think my
life went through deal making
uh initially i was extremely shy i never
liked to sell and i was even afraid to
buy remember when i was a kid
uh and my my father was we were on it on
the beach and uh me and my sister were
like toddlers so my father gave us the
money go buy ourselves some pops
popsicles or something uh i i was
actually afraid to go ahead and buy
something because i i was afraid that if
i'm gonna
uh take the product and not give enough
money then i'm gonna be a thief so
um
i i was really against this thing and i
was against deal making until it was 20
plus
but then when i started entrepreneurship
uh it occurred to me that you know this
is not going to go away so i might as
well embrace it and really learn how to
do it
um and i mean throughout my career or
whatever i've done uh deal-making was a
big big big part of it
i love it and so tell me just a little
bit about you know the the initial
journeys as an entrepreneur and
maybe a little a few of the things that
have shaped you as a leader that then
you're you're taking with you into the
different startups that you ventured
into
so uh when i uh was released from the
idf um i worked for a while as a as a
fitness instructor and uh host place
here in israel
ah wow
that's so cool
i mean then i mean roughly around 2004
2000 2005
e-commerce really started booming so i
got into affiliate marketing and i
really excelled i was actually uh
in
clickbank and cg and uh cj commission
junction were the biggest affiliate
marketplaces back then as one of the top
50 in the world
uh without knowing code
uh just you know i was a student and uh
ben gurion university and that was my
hobby and job i built funnels wow
sites i even wrote a book i didn't
really
write it myself i had a uh um you know a
provider that did that to me but that
really taught me how to build a business
from scratch it was a small business but
it taught me how to buy media and funnel
traffic into an online product do the
upsells do the cross-selling expanded
and on and on and on uh eventually i
sold more than 40 000 copies of that uh
first book that i uh
produced i don't even say i write it
because it's not
i don't deserve that title
uh
and that led me into entrepreneurship
which i then started first with value
shine more of a project-based company
than with uh um trx the gamification uh
company for online gambling companies
um this cloud b2b sas marketplace
eventually you know me which was a sales
intelligence uh platform we served
hundreds of clients and eventually we
got acquired by wework as i mentioned
before
incredible okay and so
i want to understand a little bit how
you got to this idea of
value making in deals and negotiations
through technology
what what what like what were the
different pieces that left there
so shortly after uh value shine i
started more businesses including uh
verdicats the media company
uh t-rex a gamification company for the
uh gaming industry not to say the online
gambling industry essentially
um
and discover cloud b2b sas marketplace
and then you know me and your question
relates to you know me you know me was
my previous uh
uh startup i uh founded it together with
godhoutsv
uh
and what we did essentially is we
developed a platform that helped sales
teams get more um
market insights and market intelligence
on potential uh clients on prospects uh
so we basically harbored uh data about
hundreds of hundreds of thousands of
different companies and millions of
people
so that you know sdrs and aes were able
to discover more stuff about not just
the people they're about to talk to but
also about their companies or charts
phone numbers uh funding rounds
everything you can imagine even
technology that the company is using
um that company was acquired by wework
in 2017
uh and there i found myself you know
managing uh growth projects of of
various kinds uh but the the thing about
you know me was that it was about sales
and we worked with a lot of sales teams
so i got very familiar
with the challenges of sales people and
and deal making uh not just the stuff
that we've done and we have been a lot
of big clients but also the stuff that
our clients were doing so i got a lot of
accumulated experience in this the area
of deal making and sales
so before we dive into substrata tell me
a little bit about the world of deal
making and sales from your perspective
and and what were some of the things
that you learned that that aren't so
trivial you know to the average you know
entrepreneur or
you know learner
yeah so what i discovered is that um
there's a lot of implicit stuff going on
so it's not just about having a great
product which is important
a competitive product it's not just
about the information that you relate to
the other end it's also about the more
subtle stuff it's about the nuances it's
about the dynamics between the the
seller so to speak and the buyer or the
ae in the prospect
um not just i mean it's throughout the
process it's the sdr and then the ae and
then wherever
the lead is being uh handed off to
um and the implicit stuff at least to my
um experience are the ones who you know
make the difference
they can make or break the the deal and
i think substrata in a way is uh my way
of of um
you know downloading what i know but uh
in the context of a deep learning
uh methodology and making it accessible
to to a lot of other people way better
than i could ever do it of course and
way more accurate but that was that
that's where it stemmed from essentially
incredible tell me a little bit about
substrata
so um in substrata we're using uh deep
tech
to analyze uh the power dynamics between
the two sides of the deal the buyer and
the seller it could be right for
investment bankers
it could be
proper for um
um
vcs or trying to raise from lps can be
good for b2b sales people whoever deals
with you know high-end
complex transactions there's a lot of
ego involved a lot of power games a lot
of social dynamics this is where
substrata uh shines and what we do
essentially is we analyze it
especially in the non-verbal areas
uh so that we can
we can find social nonverbal social
signals
uh that are discrete implicit
mostly covert but they can make or break
the deal and we
use that to increase the awareness of
our user which is mostly the seller
so we help basically deal makers push
the deal forward by being more attuned
more aware of the subtleties
um that are mostly nonverbal for example
uh how your voice sounds
how your body interesting you know is
seen your hand gestures your micro
expressions
even stuff in email that are not very
trivial for example uh your response
time okay your the the relative length
of your email versus the other person's
uh length of email if you are writing
your name with a um you know um
lowercase or uppercase
i know the grammatically correct way is
uppercase
but maybe uh the first letter but maybe
uh there's a certain signal that you
send out when you're actually using a
lowercase
interesting
wow i'm gonna i want to stop you there
because this is obviously something that
you know i get to partake in myself
especially in the world of venture
capital
and i honestly never stop to think that
maybe that am i am i actually you know
acting in the right way not just with in
the way that i was that i was taught in
seventh grade of how to write emails but
maybe i need to rethink about the way
that i'm that i'm presenting myself in
the in the communication sphere
now the real question that i have here
is that how how do we know where is the
source of truth how do we know what is
the right way to act because obviously
it's going to be different for every
person it's going to be different
according to the person that i'm going
to be speaking to right
well not necessarily but uh our source
of truth is the truth so we're locating
where the truth is
and uh there are you know series of
truths that we need to relate to the the
obvious one is whether the transaction
was successful or not so basically we
can reconnect to the crm and see
historically whether the deal was uh
closed one or closed lost
uh and that's one source of truth but we
always take we also take smaller steps
in that direction for example before
you're
cooking a deal uh before you even get to
the first zoom meeting or face-to-face
meeting there's there's a bunch of
emails going on whether it was inbound
outbound or an introduction
and we can um see where there's a
certain decay for example if there's a
decade it means that the email efforts
did not succeed if there's a continued
engagement it means that something is
being done properly
so
we have all sorts of of uh
in deep learning we call it error loss
uh
values that we can relate to
the this the way that you're
that then you're able to analyze it
means that you're that you need to be a
part of this process you need to be a
very intimate part of the negotiation
and deal making process so that once you
have the signal of whether the deal was
made or not you can then go back and
trace and and fine-tune those errors
when you say you you mean us as
substrata or the you
that also gives you
aftermath analysis so yeah it is part of
interaction so it follows you when
you're sending emails if you wanted to
of course uh it works alongside you when
you are doing um you know a zoom session
or whatever other conference tool you're
using
uh
and it connects your crm so it basically
escorts you throughout the process from
the first email to the
conversion point and post conversion
how do
investors say sales people how do they
react to this idea that they're going to
have this tool that is going to be with
them you know in real time giving them
feedback when you know a lot of it is
based on relationships based on
intuition how what what is sort of the
risk
how are people receptive to what's
happening here it's a big step for a
person who never heard about it um
and it this requires us to do some
market education because i think there's
a lot of
um
mystery sort of or bs mystery in sales
that people think that if you do x
this why will happen
and i think people most people don't
really recognize what's going on
uh underneath you know what's really
going on when it comes to the power
dynamics some kind of understand it but
they
they put it aside they don't really want
to confront it because uh
sometimes you're losing sometimes it's
not a good experience
uh we we look we look at it in the eyes
so to speak and we're confronting it and
uh it's it's
i don't know if it's a leap but it's at
least half a leap to really fully
recognize what we're doing it's not
trivial
what does this actually mean to the
world of sales that you know if now
we're negotiating and and a big part of
it is the relationship form of it
how does this change the dynamic of the
way that i'm acting in the negotiation
phase if now perhaps some of my words
some of my punctuation some of my
demeanor is altered by by you know by
somebody else giving me this advice
yeah so it depends on who you are so if
you are a very sad deal maker
and you you're intuitively attuned to
these aspects it's not a big change
it is a critical change because
sometimes when you lose your mojo it can
help you you know stay stay in the zone
but you really you can really you know
slip into it very easily and it's going
to be very helpful and useful uh as a
correcting tool like an invisible aid
um
for the less
savvy deal makers it's a total game
changer
because it suddenly makes them fully
aware of all the errors that they're
doing of all the stuff there that
they're um
not even thinking about
i love it because i'm guessing that
there's so much low hanging fruits that
people don't even have that person that
sits in and you know on you know flying
the wall to give them this these little
tips and advices not even things that
change their personality but things that
maybe they don't know about you know the
culture of the other person or are not
really cognizant of the way they are
responding to the way we're talking a
lot of these things right
yeah totally agree
i love it where does your you know
vision lie with this so if you're
looking at you know today's real-time
software with substrata and you're
looking more broadly about this world of
deal making negotiations a lot of the
social interaction behind making closing
sales what what is sort of the grand
vision here
my grand vision is not to be um focusing
solely on sales i think this can be
extremely helpful for uh hr for example
because of you know post code we have
more and more remote interviews
uh right i think this can be fantastic
for both sides by the way for the
interviewer or for the interviewee
um it can be also you know uh good for
the defense industry but we're not
really going that way at least not in
the present because we really don't want
to politicize the company or do anything
of that sort
but some people say and i hear that i
heard that so many times that it might
be effective for dating and to some
extent i agree it can i'm not sure we're
going to go here interesting
wow interesting and i'm guessing that
that's applicable both to those to the
real world and the and the you know the
physical world and the virtual world and
you know with the device is always
honest they can always give us some
indication
what where you know what's really
inspiring you about about your
day-to-day so one of the things that i'm
always curious about especially with
people that
that have such an incredible journey
like yours and have done different
things every day you choose to wake up
and to lead substrata so why why why do
you do what you do
i think um there's something really bold
about this and sometimes it's deterring
sometimes it actually uh eats you up
because the the challenge the technical
challenge
is extremely hard
excruciating but it's also extremely
exciting
and
there's a good feeling in the air that
we've first of all we've kind of cracked
a secret code
and that we were able to really take a a
tiny peek into the truth and then to to
make that you know accessible to others
and make it uh accurate and and uh
reliable that's a big big challenge
uh and i think i mean it's also when you
talk about nonverbal communication it's
the second language that everybody
speaks but most are not aware of think
about the fact that right
how
only you know very good politicians are
you know fluent speakers of that
language and in a way we're kind of um
commoditizing it so that more people can
enjoy
the
advantages of being more fluent and
non-verbal
not just making it the advantage of the
precious feel
i i love it and if you know if you're
looking at you know just some
traditional things that
that i or some of my friends in the
space should be looking for as you've
now spent some good amount of time
thinking about this space what what are
some things that we should be keeping in
mind as we approach no negotiations deal
making and you know from your
perspective you're looking for like uh
easy tips or something
uh not not easy tips but maybe
questions that are not trivial that we
should be asking ourselves that we may
not even know to ask just like this idea
of punctuation i never thought of asking
myself am i using the right form of
punctuation in my communication or lack
of punctuation or lack of so i think i
don't know a good question would be
i guess um
what
who do i need to be
in order for the other person
to trust me or look up to me and buy
what i'm saying interesting that would
be a good question to ask
so in other words understanding
the stakeholders you know where they're
coming from and what they may value and
what kind of persona they might be more
comfortable working with in this
specific scenario which is not
necessarily the one that you you that
you're usually portraying
yes but but it's not necessarily about
changing our character it's more about
changing our position or perceived
position in the interaction
right and putting ourselves in the other
person's shoes obviously um and if you
do that it's really gonna help i think
i love it because you're actually saying
it's not just about
changing
the it's not about being a different
person it's perhaps being the same
person but but channeling a different
type of of of energy different
different information that that is still
you but you know within an hour long
sales conversation you can't possibly
show all your sites and so it's
important to pick and choose the ones
that are more critical yes exactly
i love it now if you go back a little
bit in time what what really fascinated
you as a kid
as a kid i was um
i was a very typical kid i was extremely
fascinated with wars and fights
and conflicts
um you know i always had like groups and
they were always fighting i would go
back home and my mom would ask did you
win this one and for mom i always won
uh although the truth was not uh as
consistent
um i think what i learned as i grew up
the the interesting conflicts are not
physical
or actually they're they're implicit
they're covert
and they're they are conflicts
nonetheless sometimes you're way more
uh fierce than the physical ones
i love it what are a few words do you
choose to describe yourself
three words
um okay so
perhaps stubbornness would be something
that most people that know me would
agree i would love to say persistence
but i don't want to sound you know uh
i don't want to conflate myself too much
i'm pretty stubborn
uh when i when i decide on something
uh it's really hard to move me doesn't
mean that i don't listen actually listen
but when i'm really fixing an idea i'm
extremely stubborn
um
cognizance
um i think you mentioned that word
before so it just popped out i'm
extremely cognizant about
cognizant about
um
the stuff that are
[Music]
when you say someone you know
you either got it or you or you don't so
in my head it's like no
we can break it down
it's not that mysterious
so i really like to imagine how those
mystical processes can be broken down
into
features and stuff what is it made up
made out of
um
and i mean i don't want to say about
myself but i guess the last word would
be heart because i am a people's person
uh i'm not that kind of fierce
cruel ceo that i would uh
uh that i need to be i'm actually i have
a bigger heart
for better or for worse
ori thank you very very much i really
really enjoyed this conversation i
appreciate the time and and best of luck
with substrata i look forward to
checking out myself and and thank you
for everything stay safe and stealthy
thank you michael thank you so much
[Music]
you